I'm in London to meet Joshua Kunz he's a
hairdresser and he believes small acts
of love can make a big impact
Joshua hopes he can help the homeless
not by offering them money or food but
by giving them a haircut
the reason I start cutting hair on the
street initially was actually the
magnitude of the problem like seeing how
big this problem is in each city it's
really hard to know what to do about
that and and I think it's from that
feeling that I had to impact today I had
to do something positive to make someone
smile and realize that even if you can't
solve a problem actually it's okay to
just do your own thing and for me that's
hair dress and I love what I do so it's
a great way to be able to give someone
confidence when was the last time you
had a haircut in November last year some
again way of February five months of
March April how'd you come to be
homeless to it I broke my hip and they
stopped my benefits and at the time I
was that stupid anyone with drugs from
you I didn't really care and next thing
I remember you know they came on to
write you out that was the 24th of
January 2016 and I've been honestly you
see lots of things with homelessness and
there's lots of stereotypes and really
what I do is try and humanize this issue
because as I said this problem is so big
I think when you bring it down to one
person and tell their story that's a
great way to start and a great way for
people to understand
for me like one of the most amazing
moments is giving someone the mirror at
the end of the haircut because it's
great to see someone's reaction because
it might recognize someone they haven't
seen for a few years five four three two
one
[Music]
yeah still be sent over to the bachelors
may your new a new man right yeah thank
you
how do you feel like a new man like a
new man yeah you recognize yourself at
[Music]